[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres que la force soit avec
eux l'armoire geek lance une nouvelle
version de sa boutique dédié à la saga
star wars après les sorciers et harry
potter ce sont les héros de la galaxie
et les jedi qui s'installe à versailles
découverte des lieux en avant-première
dans quelques instants
eux semblent avoir perdu la force les
syndicats elle n'arrive plus à imprimer
leurs messages et leurs marques dans les
mouvements sociaux actuels alors que le
contexte paraît idéale avec la
multiplication des frondes la
convergence des luttes s'avère presque
improbable nous en parlerons avec pascal
guillot enseignants chercheurs à lui
vécu dans le reste de l'actualité retour
sur la fronde contre le projet de
communes nouvelles portées par quoi il
n'y a vait morte pas ou encore la
secrétaire d'état marlène schiappa qui a
installé son cabinet durant à trois
jours à trappes
c'est ce vendredi le star wars day la
journée star wars célébrée tous les
quatre mais chaque année la force était
présente ce vendredi à versailles avec
l'arrivée d'une boutique consacrée à
l'univers de la saga l'armoire geek et
star wars propose des goodies pour tous
les fans le magasin a vient tout juste
d'ouvrir ses portes après d'intenses
derniers jours de préparation
découverte des lieux avec grigoriy
canale
masque de dark vador sabre-laser mais
aussi des tapis ou des dessous de verres
à l'effigié de la saga après une
boutique harry potter versailles a
désormais son armoire geek star wars
le magasin est situé à 5 minutes à pied
seulement du château de versailles
on s'est aperçu qu'il ya énormément de
fans aussi qui sont fans de l'univers de
star wars
la magie
je tire sa force
de l'univers donc il fallait l fallait
oser c'est ce que j'ai fait une boutique
pour les fans de tout âge qu'ils aient
connu star wars aux tout débuts dans les
années 1970 ou plus récemment avec la
nouvelle trilogie et les spin off les
goodies viennent pour la plupart
d'angleterre des objets qu'ils n'étaient
généralement disponible que sur internet
que vous allez avoir laissé un livre ici
vous allez avoir dark vador et un strong
trooper je vais vous faire voir une
petite un petit produit exclusif
la mallette métallique de honsel ici un
t-shirt exclusif par rapport à l'inrs et
par rapport à en solo donc chewbacca
rétro années 4 70 80 que ça va plaire
énormément aux dames comme à ces
messieurs
l'armorique star wars organisera
également des événements premier en date
le samedi 5 mai la boutique reçoit
l'acteur tim rose qui incarne l'amiral
ackbar dans les épisodes 6 7 et 8 de la
saga
après la grève ce sont les travaux qui
vont perturber la circulation de vos
trains dans les prochains jours de
nombreux ralentissements et suppressions
sont prévues notamment sur la ligne l du
transilien lundi sera une journée très
compliqué depuis paris montparnasse
aucun train ne circulera avant midi
après midi c'est le sens province paris
qui sera impacté des travaux sont
également à prévoir sur la ligne c du
rer ce week-end plus d'informations sur
les blogs de vos lignes ou sur le site
sis à le site internet excusez-moi
transilien.com vendredi matin c'est la
circulation du réseau fait bus à
versailles qui était au ralenti le dépôt
de bus était bloqué par des cheminots de
la cgt de trappes aidés par des membres
de génération et de l'unef les
manifestants accusent la direction de la
sncf de vouloir réduire l'impact du
mouvement national des cheminots avec
justement le renfort de ses réseaux
locaux de bus grève à la sncf donc mais
aussi grève à air france défilé du 1er
mai violence de groupuscules la fête à
maquereau samedi 5 mai les mouvements et
manifestations se multiplient un peu
partout en france ces dernières semaines
mais l'incompréhension elle se
généralise 50 ans après mai 68 la
convergence des luttes tant souhaitée
par la gauche et les syndicats semble
promise à l'échec le rôle des syndicats
aussi interroge face à un président
ultra réformateurs et qui ne sembla qui
ne semble pas avoir une crainte
particulière des mobilisations sociales
sommes nous dans un contexte historico
finalement est-ce du déjà vu nous allons
poser cette question à notre invité et
d'autres aussi pascal guillot bonsoir je
vous êtes enseignant chercheur à lever
est ce qu l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
vous enseignez notamment l'histoire du
syndicalisme et des mouvements sociaux
d'un point de vue général est ce que on
en train de vivre un moment historique
tout paraît aujourd'hui très confus et
on a l'impression qu'après les vieux
partis politiques ce sont les vieux
syndicats qui sont aussi en train de
disparaître tout doucement est ce que
c'est un jugement qui est juste ou alors
qui est tronquée on assiste à une
accumulation de mécontentement c'est
vrai mais depuis un certain temps les
syndicats ont subi un certain nombre de
défaites notamment depuis 2010 et c'est
vrai qu'ils ont du mal à montrer à
convaincre de leur efficacité et d'où
les replis un peu sectoriel c'est à dire
dans différents secteurs il ya des
démobilisations qui se manifestent mais
qui ont du mal à se coordonner et on
parle de convergence des luttes mais
cette convergence a du mal à voir le
jour
et ça c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
faire entrer les syndicats dans un dans
un nouvel univers où ce c'est déjà
arrivé finalement ce sont des choses qui
arrivent dans plus d'un siècle
d'histoire pour les plus anciens
syndicats c'est vrai que c'est de la
division du monde syndical déjà mais pas
il ya un rapport de forces aussi
défavorable au monde du travail
actuellement avec l'offensive libérale
depuis les années 80 et puis c'est vrai
que depuis un certain temps le pouvoir
est beaucoup plus intransigeant avant il
était plus facile de de peser sur sur la
négociation collective grâce à la grève
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus
difficile puisque depuis disons que jean
pierre raffarin en 2003 dit ce n'est
plus la rue qui gouverne et que même
leurs maquereaux a dit récemment aussi
que là que la démocratie ne se fait pas
dans la rue
on voit bien qu'on a on a beaucoup plus
de mal à peser sur le cours des choses
et donc les syndicats sont plus dans la
défense y est ce qu on a aussi moins le
sentiment aujourd'hui quand on est
travailleur du salarié du public on a
moins le sentiment du collectif qu'on
est finalement dans un monde beaucoup
plus individualiste et que les syndicats
sont aussi touchés par sa wii c'est
beaucoup plus éclaté c'est vrai que en
effet il ya plus de grands collectifs de
travail aussi et ça ça n'aide pas il ya
aussi une segmentation
de certains secteurs il ya aussi toute
une série à une précarisation ci qui va
être pas à la mobilisation
donc toute une série de facteurs qui
montre que en effet le même si les
syndicats ont toujours leur leur leur
rôle à jouer tout à fait fondamental
c'est vrai que ils ont du mal parfois à
mobiliser l'ensemble des acteurs du
travail tout à l'heure je faisais là la
comparaison avec les anciens partis
politiques qui ont mal vécu évidemment
les dernières élections avec l'arrivée
notamment dans des manuels macro et de
son mouvement est ce que on peut aussi
faire cette comparaison avec les vieux
syndicats la cgt qui qui a été créée à
la fin du 19e siècle est ce que la cgt
par exemple n'a pas réussir à rénover
son logiciel est finalement apte à
trouver une nouvelle forme de
contestation lieu des mouvements
classiques dans la rue c'est vrai mais
alors il ya eu ce qui se passe aussi
c'est que la cgt et d'autres syndicats
sont beaucoup plus on se sont recentrés
aussi un recentrage il ya plus de
légalisme qu'auparavant et c'est vrai
que ça aussi ça pèse parce que quand par
exemple un texte dès que le processus
parlementaire abouti on pense que ça il
faut accepter que on n'a plus forcément
à lutter et ça ça ça joue aussi bien sûr
et ce recentrage est liée aussi à la
dépolitisation
il ya quand même il ya cet aspect il ya
la professionnalisation du syndicalisme
il ya aussi bien sûr là comment
dirais-je la dépolitisation et forcément
ça ne contribue pas à ça ne contribue
pas à
[Musique]
à permettre d'agir plus efficacement
puisque vous évoquez la politique on va
peut-être rappeler déjà en quoi en quoi
quel est le rôle des syndicats en france
historiquement il est peut-être bon de
rappeler qu'à la base la politique et
les syndicats ces deux choses très
distincts voilà alors c'est vrai qu'il
ya une autonomie du syndicalisme auquel
le syndicalisme est très attaché depuis
notamment la charte d'amiens de 1906 en
effet il est dit que le syndicat doit
être totalement autonome aussi bien par
rapport aux partis politiques par
rapport à l'état et ça ça reste quelque
chose de très marquant dans l'histoire
du syndicalisme
même si des partis communistes
voilà justement plus d'autonomie
aujourd'hui c'est avec la cgt a beaucoup
plus de tenues ont beau cadeau éthique
n'y a pas de lien aujourd'hui par
exemple entre la france insoumise ou en
tout cas très très très éclaté une
nouvelle fois entre la france insoumise
et et les mouvements des syndicats un
lien va le créer 10 temps passe et
garder date notamment entre le 1er mai
le 5 mai il ya une césure entre les
luttes politiques et les luttes sociales
et c'est ça aussi qui ne parvient pas à
faire affaire un effet d'entraînement et
il ya du coup certains qui essaient de
s'organiser pour essayer de que cette
cassure entre le front politique et le
front social n'existe plus il ya
soixante organisations qui sont réunis
dans le front social pour essayer
justement de peser un peu plus et de
remettre en cause cette cassure est
peut-être due justement de créer une
espèce de de convergence qui pourrait
qui pourrait déboucher sur davantage de
confidentialité
aujourd'hui quand on évoque le poids des
syndicats en france est un sujet qui
intéresse c'est évidemment beaucoup de
monde on a un chiffre c'est 8 % de
salariés français qui sont syndiqués
public privé confondus est ce que déjà
vous confirmer ces chiffres
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire une
comparaison européenne on a l'impression
que c'est très peu par exemple comparer
à la suède ou la norvège
c'est très très peu puisque la moyenne
européenne est de 23% à peu près et donc
si vous voulez en france on alors
évidemment on a annoncé 11 % fait il ya
une enquête du ministère du travail qui
a révélé que ça fait plus le taux de
syndicalisation est un peu plus élevé
que je n'imaginais qu'on voit dans tous
les médias voilà
alors c'est vrai qu'entre le secteur
marchand ou en effet on s'approche de
moins de 10
et bien sûr la fonction publique ou là
les taux de syndicalisation sont
beaucoup plus élevés vous avez chez les
cheminots à peu près 30 4% de cheminots
qui sont syndiqués
vous avez la fonction publique autour de
20% globalement donc vous avez vraiment
des différenciations très nette chez les
policiers par exemple si 49% de
saint-guy de deux policiers syndiqués au
fisc c'est aussi des taux très élevés
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya et puis à côté
de ça vous avez des endroits où en effet
le syndicalisme pénètre peu dans les
petites et moyennes entreprises et
auprès de sa auprès de travailleurs un
peu fragilisé comme les intérimaires
comme bien sûr pied aussi bien sur les
auto entrepreneurs
les chômeurs ne se syndiquent peu ce
syndic peut donc voilà vous avez
vraiment des différenciations très très
nettes mais en fait quand même si vous
avez surtout une participation très
active aux élections professionnelles
qui prouve que quand même le cndd tiens
quand même au centre c'est quelque chose
qui intéresse mais comme on explique du
cou qui est que 8% 11 % plutôt
excusez-moi de salariés en france alors
que effectivement on le voit il ya
beaucoup de manifestations la france est
connue pour être un pays très très très
très souvent en grève alors c'est une
idée reçue parfois mais c'est aussi le
cas selon les chiffres comme on explique
du coup ce décalage entre la réalité
puis puis les chiffres
oui mais je crois que si le syndicalisme
comment dirais-je et 1 s'est désolée la
non les réaliser du coup vous pensiez
comment comment on explique le décalage
entre le chiffre des 8%
mais ce sentiment que tout de même les
français sont souvent en grève et que du
coup les indics attendait ont quand même
un point important dans la société
malgré le taux de syndiqués qui est très
faible 8 ou 11 % voilà bah c'est à dire
qu'en fait je pense que le je pense que
le syndicat il a une commande ya ici un
peu professionnalisé aussi ça les gens
pense qu'effectivement le syndicat est
un peu coupé des réalités concrètes ça
c'est un souci le syndicat peut-être
n'arrive peut-être pas à répondre à
certaines interrogations notamment sur
tout ce qui concerne par exemple
l'écologie tu sais concerne par exemple
le féminisme les femmes sont très peu
représentés au sein du monde syndical
donc il ya peut-être une volonté il ya
aussi
la part des salariés une peur que le
syndicat ne soit pas ne représente pas
véritablement le monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui il ya une petite des
connexions parce que le syndicat s'est
beaucoup professionnalisé
il ya même d'ailleurs des dirigeants
syndicaux qui ont marre a atteint qui
ont eu des risques politiques par
exemple le directeur de cabinet adjoint
de vin pénicaud et est en effet issu de
fo donc il ya cette confusion des genres
aussi entre le politique et le social
c'est à dire les gens pensent que en
effet le mal gré en dépit de ce qu'on a
dit à l'heure que le syndicat est
toujours à la remorque du politique
une question très rapide sur cette
convergence des luttes cinquante ans
plus tard 50 ans après mai 68 on a
l'impression est pour l'instant c'est
clair que que le que c'est loupé y aura
pas de convergence des luttes pour les
syndicats et les mouvements de gauche
est ce que vous pensez que c'est
définitivement raté pour eux ou alors
que finalement le mois de mai est encore
assez long et qui pourrait se passer
beaucoup de choses à voir et dire voilà
le printemps n'est pas terminée en effet
il peut y avoir en effet il peut y avoir
un mouvement de mouvement qui peut
surgir même si c'est très difficile
parce qu'il est justement l'état cherche
à jouer sur le pourrissement sur
l'épuisement et ça on a une
intransigeance du pouvoir politique
comme je disais aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de mobiliser
dans ces conditions mais il ya quand
même encore d'aider les syndicats sont
un contrepoids au tennis je n'ai pas
m'en voilà il ya encore un
contre-pouvoir aujourd'hui qui existent
et qui permet peut-être de de répondre
aux interrogations du monde du travail
merci pascal guillot d'être venu sur
notre plateau et d'avoir répondu à
toutes nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes enseignant
chercheur à lui est ce qu merci et bon
au ghana vous aussi beaucoup je remercie
on passe tout de suite à au résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
un déplacement de trois jours marlène
schiappa et son cabinet se sont
installés à trappes mercredi jeudi et
vendredi la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
a multiplié les rencontres de terrain
sur cette thématique durant trois jours
elle s'est notamment rendue au centre de
formation sur les droits des femmes et
des familles locales ou dans une
pépinière d'entreprises la rédaction de
tv 78 vous proposera lundi un reportage
complet sur ces trois jours de
déplacement à trappes dans son journal
d'information locale première diffusion
lundi du coup 7 mai à 18 heures ils ont
dévoilé leur volonté il ya tout juste un
mois les maires de maurepas et
coignières veulent rassembler leur ville
pour former une nouvelle commune un
projet détonnant qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité
si le lancement de l'étude sur la fusion
a été voté mercredi soir en conseil
municipal à maurepas les habitants de
coignières eux se sont rassemblés devant
la mairie une mobilisation pour
s'opposer au projet reportage de mélanie
poquet et grégory canal et de ville pour
un même projet deux ambiances ce
mercredi 2 mai elle était électrique
devant la mairie de coignières où devait
se tenir le conseil municipal finalement
annulée en raison des soucis de santé du
maire jean-pierre sevestre près de 200
personnes réunies pour dire non à la
création d'une commune nouvelle
il regrette la soudaineté de l'annoncé
craignent une perte d'identité de
coignières au profit de maurepas je
tiens à l'identité de poignard de caen
aériens se sont mobilisés cet homme et
se mobiliseront encore si c'est
nécessaire pour qu un poignet
rennes ne soit pas rayer de la carte de
la france
doit être mis devant le fait accompli
c'est vraiment inadmissible on a
découvert en fait que j'avais ce projet
de fusion qui n'était pas forcément
prévu donc ça nous a forcément
interpellé est amené à être curieux sur
le sujet à vouloir en savoir plus une
volonté de rapprochement annoncé le 9
avril dernier l'une des raisons avancées
pour ce projet faire face à la baisse de
la dgf les dotations de l'état
à voir toutes les capacités d'aborder
les différents dossiers les différents
projets que nous pouvons avoir notamment
les projets importants que nous avons
sur la ville de coignières sur les
années à venir
l'argument n'est pas recevable pour les
membres de l'opposition à coignières à
l'origine du rassemblement
car les finances de la commune sont
saines une fusion entraînerait pour eux
en revanche une forte augmentation des
impôts locaux
mais c'est dgf ne représentent que 7 %
de nos recettes de fonctionnement
donc c'est presque rien ici on a des
entreprises on a tout ça donc c'est
presque rien on peut totalement se
passer de la dgf c'est peut-être pas la
même situation à maurepas une pétition
pour demander la tenue d'un référendum
local sur le sujet a été lancée elle
aurait recueilli près de 1500 signatures
à coignières ou le projet ne passe pas
has également pour quelques élus la
majorité ils seraient huit membres du
groupe majoritaire sur 17 à s'opposer à
la création d'une commune nouvelle avec
maurepas nous sommes quelques-uns
dans certains sont des membres du bureau
municipal à avoir donné un avis très
défavorable à la fusion qui nous paraît
être un projet a suffisamment mûrs en
tout cas en l'état actuel des choses et
d'autre part c'est un c'est une fusion
qui est très déséquilibré au détriment
de notre commune au même moment ce
mercredi 2 mai se tenait le conseil
municipal à maurepas l'ambiance était
chaude et quelque peu après un échange
houleux avec le premier adjoint et
roanne le gall
l'élu d'opposition ps ismaila vannes a
décidé de quitter l'assemblée le conseil
municipal a finalement adopté le
lancement de l'étude concernant la
création d'une commune nouvelle avec
coignières deux élus n'ont pas pris part
au vote dont ismaila vannes 4 se sont
abstenus pas d'opposition un
rapprochement avec coignières sur le
fond mais tout s'est fait beaucoup trop
vite
la communication a été très mal faite
c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'il y
avait certainement des choses à voir
ensemble de façon à ce que chacun soit
gagnant malgré l'approbation de maurepas
le dossier de fusion est pour le moment
stopper temps que le conseil municipal
de coignières n'aura pas valide et
également le lancement de l'étude
commune entre les deux villes une fois
que les études ont été votés du côté de
coignières on pourra aller lancer
ensuite engager la suite en tout cas
nous avons un calendrier nous souhaitons
poursuivre les réunions publiques et les
ateliers de travail et que les habitants
au moins avant l'été avant d'arriver au
vote avant la fin d'année dans un
communiqué distribué aux habitants lors
du rassemblement la municipalité de
coignières indique qu'elle va organiser
une concertation collective pour décider
de la suite donnée au projet de création
d'une commune nouvelle avec maurepas à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines toujours cette
semaine a été franchi une nouvelle étape
pour les travaux du pont aux couleurs la
structure qui relie la ville de la
verrière à maurepas en passant au dessus
de la n10 il y a quelques jours les
ouvriers ont coulé le béton sur le
nouveau tablier du pont les détails avec
ce sujet de nicolas d'andré
la dernière phase des travaux du pont
schuller est enclenché la nouvelle
partie du pont a été bétonné par les
ouvriers une épaisseur de 70 cm coulé
sur le thème biblique il ya des équipes
qui y vivre le béton le béton il faut
qu'ils soient libres et pour faire
sortir les bulles d'air et il ya
d'autres équipes qui sont en train de
faire le tas le sage qu'on appelle
couramment des dallages y est
on pourra voir pour avoir une surface
vraiment liste pour rappel cette partie
du pont sera destiné à la circulation
des bus dans les deux sens avec
l'objectif de fluidifier le trafic
routier sur cet itinéraire c'est la
dernière étape
on a vraiment du béton après derrière on
va passer qu'on appelle les finitions de
la mise en place de l'étanchéité la mise
en place des garde corps périphériques
et l'habillage en termes de serrurerie
dont et pornichet l'extérieur et donc
tout ça ça nous amène si vous voulez en
gros le pont il serait très circulent
avons septembre 2018
les ouvriers entameront à ce moment là
une phase de rénovation du pont existant
la circulation se fera sur la nouvelle
partie de l'infrastructure l'ensemble
des travaux devraient se terminer à la
fin de l'année 2018
un projet qui fait débat à jouy en josas
cette fois ci l'ancien site de thales
sera bientôt transformé en centre de
formation pour réfugiés 300 personnes
tous les six mois devrait recevoir sur
place notamment des cours pour apprendre
le français
ce dossier piloté par l'association
emmaüs solidarité est critiqué par
certains habitants mais surtout par le
front national qui réclame une
consultation des habitants sur le sujet
les détails avec ce reportage grillage
fermé locaux vides depuis près de neuf
mois l'ancienne université thales
devrait rouvrir ses portes d'ici
quelques semaines pour se transformer en
centre de formation pour réfugiés avec
le soutien de la préfecture
d'ile-de-france et emmaüs solidarité 300
personnes suivront des cours sur place
durant six mois
objectif leur enseigner le français et
faciliter leur intégration
professionnelle
un projet est allé en tout sur 9 ans
auquel s'est ralliée la mairie après
avoir préempté le terrain il y à plus
d'un an
on y adhère je dirais par un parent par
nécessité par obligation mais on y
adhère aussi parce que c'est un projet
qui nous semble avoir du sens nous
semble avoir du sens que de former que
de près former des personnes réfugiées
en france qui ont de petits bénéficient
du droit d'asile de façon à leur
permettre de s'intégrer dans les
meilleures conditions dans la société
française dévoilée dans le détail aux
habitants début avril lors d'une réunion
publique le projet suscite depuis des
réactions entre inquiétude et étonnement
pour certains il est aussi critiquée par
le front national qui réclame la tenue
d'un référendum local sur le sujet la
proportion
ce centre est assez inédite ça va
évidemment modifier le visage de la
ville
je pense que les premiers concernés sont
les personnes à la vie mais qui est
aussi les élus et les personnes qui
habitent versailles grand parc parce que
les infrastructures vont être aussi
sollicité sur l'ensemble de versailles
grand parc face aux demandes d'un
scrutin local la mairie assure que le
conseil municipal est légitime en la
matière et qu'un ancien référendum
n'avait réuni que 2 100 votants sur cinq
mille électeurs potentiels
le maire est également en discussions
avec les différentes parties pour
faciliter le suivi et l'évaluation du
projet les premiers réfugiés devrait
loger et suivre des cours dans la
verdure jova sienne d'ici mi juin une
visite des lieux est prévue au préalable
pour les habitants intéressés aient des
déchets à perte de vue depuis plusieurs
années la plénière agricole de carrières
sous poissy est victime de déchargement
sauvage aujourd'hui la situation est
devenue critique les détritus jonchent
le sol sur 25 hectares et laisse courir
des risques sanitaires et pour
l'environnement pour faire face à la
situation au manque de réactions
politiques et des collectivités les
habitants et associations se sont
emparés du sujet anthony effroi le
président deux rives de seine nature
environnement était sur notre plateau
mercredi soir pour évoquer cette
actualité son association vient de
déposer plainte auprès du procureur de
la république de versailles extraits il
ya beaucoup de matériaux qui présente
une dangerosité importante on a des
plaques d'amiante qui sont concassés
dont ils peuvent justement
entraîner des dispersions de ses
paillettes d'amiante et donc avoir un
effet sur sur les populations on a un
certain nombre de solvants aussi qui
sont déversés comme sa mère totalement
sauvage en pleine nature
donc tout ça on estime qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des incidences 1 /
évidemment l'environnement et puis aussi
probablement sur la santé des riverains
donc on souhaite que les services de
l'état s'empare aussi ce dossier et des
habitants et des associations calcula
vote se sont emparés du sujet votre
association ça fait combien de temps
qu'elle est sur le banc ça fait plus
d'un an déjà qu'on a alerté
les différents pouvoirs publics on a
alerté le préfet des yvelines on a
alerté les maires des communes
concernées
les députés des deux circonscriptions
également concernés on a aussi proposé
un certain nombre de solutions qu aurait
permis dans un premier temps de
sécuriser la plaine et donc d'empêcher
les nouveaux apports malheureusement nos
demandes de tables rondes ont jamais
reçu une suite favorable et on n'a pas
eu vraiment beaucoup d'écouté de la part
eau ni la communauté urbaine grand paris
seine et oise ni l'ensemble des élus du
secteur
on referme cette émission avec le
printemps des animaux organisé ce
week-end pour la première fois au refuge
de plaisir de la spa de plaisir deux
jours de portes ouvertes pour favoriser
les rencontres entre familles et animaux
de compagne et au refuge de plaisir plus
de 200 chats et près de 120 chiens sont
en attente d'un foyer et aussi de câlins
rendez vous donc sur place entre eux est
10 heures et 18 heures samedi 5 et
dimanche 6 mai c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo autour de l'actualité en direct
lundi à 18h sur l'antenne de tv 78 d'ici
là vous pouvez rester connectés et
informés grâce à notre site internet tv
et 78 points comme et notre application
aussi tv soixante dix huit bon week-end
à tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]